Hello internet!
Hiya, how's it going?
Are you asking me or the internet?
I don' care about you,
so I'm asking the internet.
I assume they are fine,
because they are watching
The Slow Mo Guys video--
Big time.
On the internet.
Well, today we've got a
car airbag, haven't we?
I was always amazed that,
when an airbag goes off in a
car, in the steering wheel,
I thought:
How does the airbag not hit
the driver in the face?--
Yes, just think of it as a big smack.
How does it just deploy in his face?
And it turns out airbags
deploy so immensely fast,
that usually, they are
fully out and inflated
before the driver has even
moved from the impact.
So let us see how fast that
really is by filming it
at two and a half thousand
frames a second in HD,
with a fan of flex.
Got batteries, so yeah,
I'm going to connect them up,
so hopefully that would work,
but I'm a bit scared about
this one to be honest.
All right Dan.
Wear this for safety.
I don't want--
I'm a bit scared!
All right, go for it!
What?
Go for it!
Bloody hell!
me!
That was fast!
Oh my god.
Bloody heck.
Did you see me jump?
No!
I myself.
Oh.
Whoa!
That's fast!
That is so fast!
Look at it flapping about!
That's straight in your face!
Now you noticed the
airbags never just explode,
because they are actually
vented at the back.
See this here?
The explosion puts air into a
bag that is not even sealed.
Ah!
So that air can leak out without the bag
just exploding form the pressure.
Did not know that.
Pretty cool, isn't it?
Yeah, it's pretty awesome.
Also, very hot!
Yeah, I felt that afterwards,
I've touched it and it
was actually really warm.
All right, so we have a second airbag.
Yep.
That first one went off,
but you can't really--
Really.
See any sort of scale of speed,
we have got to try and drop something
next to this one, right?
Yeah, so you turn it right.
So you drop something
as this one goes off.
I see you are using a standard
procedure kitchen knife.
This would not be a slammer guys,
if we did not have the
completely incorrect
equipment to use though.
Ready?
Yeah.
Woo!
Where did it go?
me!
Over there!
By the tree!
Jesus Christ!
Holy crap!
Oh my god!
Good lord!
Literally, that all happened so quickly,
I blinked, the airbag was over there,
and the glass was about
30 meters over there.
Why am I so confused as to
everything that is over there?
Hard to say, you just go like duff!
What happened?
This was much bigger than the other one.
It had a lot more volume to it, didn't it?
Yeah, it was like...
I guess you are further away from it--
It looked softer--
when you are from serial mode.
But it is the same fabric as the other.
So yeah, that shot up here,
and as I dropped the water
bottle-- the glass of water,
hit the table, and shot off.
Look how far it went.
Really quickly, as well.
And bearing in mind, it
didn't get shot up in the air,
It just got shot along the floor.
It, like, hit the floor sometimes.
I'd say it is about 25 meters maybe.
What is that at your feet?
Oh.
That is amazing!
We are miles away.
It is.
And the glass of hope.
Yeah.
Available in the risky store.
Well, I hope you enjoyed that video.
Please follow us on Twitter.
Do those things.
Yeah, and be careful if you crash a car.
We are going to dispose of the airbag now.
Careful from the poison, yeah?
Yeah.
This video was sponsored by Audible.com.
They have over 150,000 audio books.
Go to Audible.com/SLOWMO for a free book.
I recommend Philip Pullman's
The Amber Spyglass.
It is from His Dark Materials trilogy.
It is a really good book.
It is about this thick,
so I am proud of being able to read it,
so if you got to Audible.com,
you can listen to it.
Much easier.